With respect to the three other blackboard qualities, performance,
because there's a lack of well-defined control flow, may lead to redundant and
administrative behavior.
For example, the polling of a repository.
Maintainability is enhanced because having independent com,
components can lead to in, increased flexibility.
But if we make changes to the common control paradigm wherein the blackboard
components are updating the repository, or if we change the repository's data
format, this can have pervasive negative effects on maintainability.
As far as safety is concerned, because the blackboard is a common repository
accessible to all the components, if you somehow get bad data un, that
might lead to a safety problem, this can easily spread to the other components.